and with one kiss i'll be united with my
one true love oh my princess you're more
beautiful than I could have ever
imagined
I'm yours forever forever forever ride
with me to gundalia your castle and our
marital chambers await yeah I'm good
actually yeah I've got a thing with the
troll later he's trying to put a hex on
my sister it's like a whole thing but
but we must be married at once and am I
not to know what you so desired is it is
it me no well yeah kind of let me prove
my love to you my kiss will speak louder
than words okay
no you can't I'm sorry I'm SuperDuper
gay you don't want to be with me I mean
it's not you you it's just like you so
I'm just not your type
yeah you could say that what would be
your type like Rapunzel I can grow my
hair up and that's so sweet of you to
offer
I just need certain places to be
you know gentler rounder maybe I just
need to get drunk on the King's finest
wine
yeah drinking makes me care actually
maybe we could just be good friends for
seven to nine months and let the
romantic tension build yeah I don't
think that's gonna happen buddy hey
there there come on champ
look you seem great
you're objectively handsome polite I
just hoped that when I finally got to
kiss my frog that the person that popped
up would have less of a Venus yeah I'm
sorry about all this I hope you weren't
a frog for too long
no syndrome - I've never encountered a
lady who lays with maidens really I
doubt that
well perhaps Magda who cares for the
horses what kind of shoes does she wear
this table
homemade leather steel toed boots gay no
she couldn't possibly she's mother's bed
woman and she's certainly not oh dollars
listen I have tons of single straight
maiden friends I could set you up with
really yeah Duchess Gweneth and Lord
Chadwick just recently cut ties I can
call her for you if you want I love that
very much perhaps we could just and have
a goblet sometime absolutely take care
and what about the witch that hexed me
super gay splendid next time on lesbian
princess I hope she's blonde